good afternoon we and our
live hello good afternoon my name is
Vincent G I'm the director general of
the ftth council
Europe and I would like to um welcome
you to this new uh session of um our
webinar series the title for today's
session is Dodge telecom's Journey to
accelerate ftth
deployment and before I introduce you to
our speakers uh I would like to spend a
few minutes uh to to explain a bit more
um the U the series of webinar we're
presenting and run you through some
housekeeping item so if you can move to
the next slide
please um for those who are not familiar
with our organization the ftth council
is a trade Association we are regrouping
uh 160 member um both um coming from the
vendor Community operator community and
investors under the objective to promote
full fabon Network as the most future
prooof and sustainable uh Broadband
access technology uh for the benefits of
European Citizen and
businesses we are conducting uh multiple
um studies work uh we are advocating uh
towards policy makers but we're also
educating um the ecosystem and this
series of webinar is part of our effort
to share insights and knowledge about
our industry next
slide so this series um takes place um
once every three weeks once every month
and is sponsored by typically the member
of the ftth council and today's session
is sponsored by iqg uh with two
representative RF mesman and yonas Fest
IO being very active member of the ftth
Council next
slide so some some uh very practical
information the the session is recorded
every um person having registered to the
session will have access to the replay
we will also share the deck which will
be used by our presenters so the deck
will will be reachable uh via the thank
you email you will
receive you are welcome to ask questions
uh um we will dedicate uh 10 15 minutes
toward the end of the presentation to
answer this question to do so you need
to use uh the question section of the
control panel you must have on your
screen so do not hesitate to type the
question we will do our very best to
address most of them in case because
there are many attendees today in case
we cannot take your question they will
be forwarded to uh the sponsor and
participant to to this session and and
I'm sure they'll come back to you in one
way or
another so with that I would like to
move to the next slide and hand it over
to Raph mesman who is leading IQ goo for
Europe and Raph will tell you more about
the topic of today and introduce the
following
presenters
RF yes thank you very much Vincent for
the introduction and also from me yes a
very warm welcome to everyone here on
this web I'm really excited to be able
to present to you today a customer use
case uh on the usage of um com of fiber
within the context of the deut Telecom
project and happy to have our guest
speakers from deut Telecom joining us um
now uh first I want to give you a a
short uh intro to IQ for those who are
not familiar with the company um our
vision within iqg is that we are helping
our customers really build building
better networks and we do that with a
quite unique single integrated solution
that can help all the operators to
support the the whole life cycle of the
network so um all the way from the
planning and design stage through to the
construction and then ultimately
operating the network and of course also
connecting customers in order to
generate uh revenue and we do that in a
way that uh is quite unique from one
source of Truth one platform that under
pins all these different parts of the
life
cycle now um for those who are uh also
familiar with comsof as a company and as
a brand uh so since August 22 I and
comsof have joined forces and um given
the fact that our Technologies are very
complementary uh this now fits into this
endtoend life cycle story uh obviously
being one company now with a broad set
of solutions and where the comes of uh
brand is mostly reflecting the automated
design
Solutions um as a joint company we um
have more than 450 customers across the
world and more than 100,000 users that
are uh daily using our software
something we are very proud of uh we are
with more than 300 employees spread
across our eight offices uh that are
spread also around the world and I I
think what's um differentiating us from
some other companies is that we really
come from a a real understanding of the
networks and um the support of the
workflows uh we we uh start from the
business problem and um look at
implementing solutions to solve those
business uh challenges and that with a
team with a lot of experience in this
domain and like I said spending the
whole life cycle it's also a system that
is very modern uh cloud-based um Mo very
um easily supporting Mobility workflows
Etc now um the comsof brand as I said is
is the part that focuses more on the
automated design so the earlier stages
of a typical life cycle of a fiber
network uh and as such comsof product is
a global market leader in automated
design with uh a history of almost 20
years of supporting FD rollout projects
across the world with some of the
biggest projects out there and of course
we're very happy today to uh zoom in a
bit more on on one of the projects we're
very um happy and proud of uh
collaborating with which is the project
together with doche
Telecom we uh are working together with
doche Telecom since
2018 where at that time the challenge
was set forward to accelerate the ftph
rollout um to at least three million
homes per year at that stage um and
increasing while doing so the quality
and the consistency of designs Dutch
Telecom selected com off as a solution
of course integrating that into a wider
workflow which we will learn more about
in a few minutes and the results I think
are very interesting to see reaching
those highspeed uh or high true put uh
per month uh with a high level of
quality um and again uh we'll come back
to that uh in the in the following
slides so our speakers for today I'm
very happy to be joined by battle F
schimelman and Henning wolf from do
Telecom who are heavily involved in this
journey and in this project but before
handing off to them I'll hand off to
yonas for who is within iqg responsible
for the comes of fiber product and who
will first give us a quick run through
of what comes of fiber is unas floor is
yours thank you yes so I want to start
uh giving High LEL introduction of commo
fiber um with commo fiber we want to
focus on two main questions that uh
operators engineering firms have um when
rolling out a new fiber Network for a
Target area how do I roll out that new
network what does that Network look like
uh what equipment do I need uh to
connect all of the homes uh in my target
area and how can I do this as cost
effective uh as possible how can I keep
my costs under control well with com of
fiber which is a software solution we
try to do this uh by using design
Automation and optimization uh in many
different ways and I'm going to uh walk
you through that here so um the way that
compo fiber uh Works uh is that um it
takes a set of rules and costs that are
really driving the optimization so you
provide information on your network
architecture for example cabinet size or
the maximum distance uh that you can go
to connect uh homes you provide a list
of material and Equipment all the cables
ducts closures U manholes and so for
that you can use to build uh this new
network and you give it a set of costs
and constraints so um all the equipment
have a particular cost uh they have some
uh constraints on the amount of fibers
for example for cable
um there's cost for your Civil Works for
trenching for aerial um or for reusing
existing
infrastructure um and there can be
constraints on a closure size for
example or um the the size of a manhole
and the amount of closures that it can
take and all of that information is
considered by the software and is
driving the optimization
algorithms second point is the gis data
so um it's really GIS driven uh to get
to uh yeah particular detail in in
accuracy particular level in accuracy um
and it's also driving the cost of the
design um so yeah typical JS input data
that's required is landbased data like
the addresses Parcels um and streets
within your target
area um any existing infrastructure so
that's a huge uh cost driver as as you
will also see in in the presentation
later on um reusing existing uh com
existing cables uh and and structures is
a is a way that cost can be um yeah cost
can be lowered um so that's important
that that is also taken into account in
the uh the design
Automation and then other cost driving
factors like surface information natural
boundaries uh all of that detail
information the more detail that you
provided the better the algorithms uh
will work and uh the more accurate the
cost will
be as a result of a cons on fire
calculation uh you get very detailed uh
output U from the solution out of the
box so it gives you uh cost breakdown
complete cost overview of um of building
out your new
network this goes into a lot of uh
details so you get a deta detailed
breakdown all the equipment all the
Civil Works that are needed together
with um yeah the volume and the total
cost so you can do a very detailed
analysis and maybe optim your rules to
drive down costs even
further this goes this this cost
information can also be provided even
for individual addresses for your Target
area again driving uh your decisions to
maybe exclude uh certain homes from an
initial roll out and connect them later
on to then optimize the budget uh that
you have for targeting in a new
area and uh what is very important I
think and and helps with with increasing
the accuracy avoiding errors um and and
gaining time is that the output that's
generated by conso fiber is really a a
detail design so there's fiber level
connectivity allowing you to to trace
through the network so it's not only
providing the equipment that you need to
build out the network but also which
connections are required like um yeah
which fibers need to be connected to
which other fibers uh the cables and
which particular microct do they do they
need to be positioned so all of this can
be taken into account by the
software and last uh point which I think
is a a key feature when uh going to uh
low-level design and constructible
Designs is giving control to the user so
it's not so Comer fire is not a blackbox
solution that gives you a design and and
you need to uh go with that no you can
really have control so you can um you
can um make decisions decide where your
cabinet location needs to be where which
homes are connected to which cabinet for
example and let the software then do the
heavy lifting and uh yeah decide the
connectivity again decide all the
equipment that needs to be placed to um
yeah to connect all of the homes that
you told the software to uh to connect
so you still have that level of control
uh it's not a blackbox um
solution now with this functionality we
can offer yeah we see with our customers
were offering uh different types of of
values first thing that's obvious it's
it's a time-saving uh solution right
compared to manual design uh saving time
for 50 to 90% in the endtoend planning
and design process the second point
which is which is really important is um
it's generating cost-effective design so
it's helping to reduce the the build
cost of your network definitely when
looking to reuse existing infrastructure
as efficiently as as
possible a third point is uh you get
better designs so you get uniform
designs uh the quality is increased
because you have a certain set of rules
that need to be followed if you're uh
making change it to the design and
you're not adhering to the rules you get
notified uh by the software so it
detects this um and and it modifies you
so that you can uh you can adjust the
design accordingly it also helps to
avoid mistakes when doing a manual
design it's easy to miss a fiber or um
yeah foree the wrong type of cable so
that you cannot connect homes maybe in a
later phase and this is all taken care
of by the
software and lastly it's it's cost
control so already in your design phase
in your planning phase you get a very
detailed view on your cost um all the
costs are generated or calculated based
on a real Network design following the
rules so the reduction in cost variation
between design and build is greatly
lowered so you get a lot of confidence
in the cost that you get from com fiber
design compared to the cost that will
take to eventually build build a
network so this was a quick overview of
conso fiber with this I'm going to hand
it over to
eold thanks a lot
J uh
um let me also share my
screen um okay so um based on compo
fiber and with com fiber in um in our
portfolio we we basically um established
a program in DOD Telecom but let me
first give you a quick introduction I'm
assuming many of you are familiar with
DOD Telecom as a company but um we we're
basically um Germany's largest
telecommunication company company um we
have like uh around 60 million mobile
customers we have around uh 20 million
fiber connections um out of which 7
million approximately are FC uh you
connections uh or customers we can serve
um we have had a massive buildout of our
s footprint in the last couple of years
um I think 2022 we had 2 million 2023
with 2.5 million 2024 is going to be 2.
and or between 2.5 and 3 million again
um so we are massively ramping up um our
ftth
footprint um and um yeah in in yeah 2023
alone or this year we we by now have
approximately 3/4 of a million
kilometers in fiber Cable in the ground
um and one of the main assets that
helped build all of this um in the last
couple of years was the establishment of
the ftth factory which is an endtoend
process um to enable the fiber planning
and construction process and that's
exactly what I what are what we want to
give you a little bit more details about
um so the ftth factory process um starts
off um with a um first an environmental
recording um Henning is going to give
you a little bit more details about that
in a second um where we sent out T cars
out uh we then start off in the next
process step um where we take the data
that is recorded uh by the car and use
AI
components um to do a automatic
classification of the surface um and do
then based on that also an automatic
calculation of the potential trench
Network we then start into the structure
planning um where the comsof uh
components are embedded um go into
virtual exploration um which is the
process step where we do the permitting
uh process go then in a detailed design
um or detail planning process um and
lastly hand over to a digital
construction support step um where we
support the construction itself um and
the uh the
documentation and with that Hing I would
pass over to you for the environmental
recording thank you
so our first step and our ftth Factory
process is as Bel said a 3D and 2D
environmental recording here we have um
currently four T cars So-Cal T cars so
that Maga um car you see on the screen
uh driving around all of Germany so this
car is equipped with a lot of um cameras
and um GPS receivers and 3D uh
environmental sensors so that uh all
details of um yeah
construction uh area is recorded by this
car and cently these cars are um sent to
the city ahead of an ftth roll out and
the data is currently also only used for
this ftth roll out and is not made
available for any uh third parties and
as you can see um on the slide um yeah
the cars nearly drove 150,000 kilometers
to today in the last three to four
years next slide
better sorry it's slow coming
up okay so let's have a closer look on
our automated Network design in which we
use a conso fiber designer so the first
step is to collect all the data gathered
by the T car and this data is processed
test um to in an automated way um so
that there's an automated classification
going on on the surfaces so that uh we
know on which side of the street which
surface is present so there are
approximately 30 trained classes for it
for example asphal and concrete pavement
so all these different surfaces um are
um collected and identified by our
automated process and out of this data
we generate uh the potential the so-call
potential trenches which are then later
used by comsoft so these are um the
potential ways our Network um could be
buil or ft Network could be built inside
one um roll out area and of of course
this surface informations are written to
this uh potential trenches so we exactly
know um on which um on which side of the
street which surface is present and of
course how many uh how much this um side
of the street would cost and these
informations are then passed to our um
integration of the Comm of fiber
designer and uh so we generate a really
cost optimized and good ftth Network
design also under also utilizing our
existing
infrastructure
and we already yeah thanks better we
already generated um like we already
calculated in somewh like 12 million
demand points over the last few years so
you can see in 2022 we started with uh
one one million um households um to be
calculated by com off and now we are
yeah nearly to five million in this year
and also this automated process reduced
our for up to 20 up to 75% here so um in
previous processes our Network designers
really had to draw these ftth areas
manually and that was not a nice job and
and so um we have a real good benefit
here by using our by using koft and head
to the next slide so I would give you a
little bit um of experience here with
working together with
kof yeah here it is um so in do Telecom
we had um here a special situation that
um we already have a lot of existing
pipes and all and and previously built
fibers and so on in our um yeah our um
company so we wanted of course to reuse
all these existing infrastructure um
which have been built over the years and
our for our ftth roll out to reduce the
cost and there we have you pretty
challenging um things to do with comsoft
because we had a lot of special
situations different pipe different
conduit types and so on and all these
informations had to be um had to be
calculated or had to be taken into
account by the the comsof F designer and
I really must say that comsoft did a
good job here and gave us a lot of
support to understand these different
situations and how to handle these in in
an automated way so in this
case thanks to to comsof again for for
supporting us here so now we gener let's
go back to the slides um so we generate
our ftth Network design here
so sorry SL back thank you um so as you
can see on on the on the screen we have
our distribution points distribution
areas these are the the the
um the colard polygons and so on so all
this this network design is is
calculated automatically and uh no
Telecom employee has to yeah has to do
it manually and we only our Telecom
employees only do a short quality check
on this automated Network design and
that's all our um our employees have to
do here and now you can go to the next
Slide by way
okay The Next Step um during um our
automated ftth R out process um is the
so-call um
um there's no real good English term for
it so we have to ask our
um our local um authorities where we can
put these cabinets and so on and there
we we also use our gather data we
collect via the cars and we have our we
have this um tool here so-called fiber
3D and then this tool you we can really
um change the position of each cabinet
um in a 3D automate in a 3D way so that
um we can really um say okay we want to
place this cabinet here and then no one
is blocked by this cabinet and so on and
in previous times our colleagues always
have to drive into town and take this
photos um manually and also draw this
cabinet on a PDF file and we found an
nice it supported way here to do to to
um so that our colleagues don't have to
do this anymore and this was also real
beneficial during the um pandemic so we
could coordinate the locations of these
cabinets together U with the local
councils we are the internet and no one
has had to meet on onsite and um what we
here um so we approve these locations by
the local authorities and then we
transfer these locations back to the
coms of designer so that these changed
locations are taken into account um in
the new network design and another
benefit of this um 3D um software is
that we can record the conditions uh of
the road before the roll out so for
example if a local Authority says okay
my street water in the better condition
before your roll out please do it again
we can prove oh no your your scet was
not in a better condition you can can
have this uh picture of
it and another addition you can see on
the in the video is that uh all the cars
are blurred so first we wanted to blur
only the license plate but this was
quite challenging because um the license
plates have different designs in each
country so that we would have to gather
a lot of training data for our automated
blurring so and this was so huge afford
that we just decided to blur all the
cars because car cars look mainly the
same all across the
countries and the last step I wanted to
show you here is this um this document
you can see on the left side of the
screen this document is also generated
manually when previous time this has
always had to be created manually so
this is really an created automatically
and then our employee can send this to
the local Authority and then the local
and Authority can sign this document and
this is really the the approval that we
can build our cabinet at that
location yeah next
slide yeah the last step of our um
planning process so after all of our
locations and path and so on were
approved by the local
authorities uh we go to the detail in
and um this software is so-called um
PLU um and this is um in based on a
based on qgis it's an um telom made
Telecom tail solution um for detail
planning and where we just um import the
network design created by comsof and the
only the main thing the users do in this
detail planning is to they just change a
little bit um if necessary on the
network design so just small things as
soon as some bigger changes are
necessary then of course we reuse um the
comop design to to just generate a new
network design and um we also generate
the construction documents out of the
software um and the last thing that I
wanted to show you here that the
software is multi tendent so also
externals or um other compan which work
together with DOD Telecom can can reuse
the software and yeah the for here um
has also been you pretty reduced because
in our old with our old uh detail
planning software uh we would have such
an equal um construction area an employe
would work up to 300 working days on
this on the design um until this
construction documents are generated and
now we could reduce this aort to an
average of 30 days also by um also
because comsof is calculating so many
components inside this network so as um
as previously said so we know where each
fber each fiber is going and how it's
connected so that um we really could put
reduce this affort up to 90% to 30 Men
Days yeah and the next step uh in our
ftth planning process would be the
digital trench recording and here I
would hand back over to B thank
you thanks a lot Hing um so yes the next
step is basically then the digital
construction support um which basically
consists of two main components so we
have on the one hand a mobile
application so we um or together with a
a partner we implemented a system it's
this one's called goas um which supports
the automatic measurement of um of yeah
open trenches and open constructions um
basically just have a mobile phone you
walk along the trench and the open
construction and it records uh using the
LI skin of the iPhone it records the um
the trench uh three-dimensionally and is
um capturing also um relevant data um in
uh supports submitting that into our um
web app there are also alternative um
Solutions available for this so we
support um goas the one that we also um
work together with our partner with um
but um there's also deep up and
potentially in the future other
solutions that we then
support um that data is then uh
submitted once captured into our um
digital construction web app and so the
the benefit of this whole solution for
us is um that uh on the civil
engineering side um it's a much easier
in much more streamlined process uh to
actually get the data to us you don't
need a um a field surve in every
instance in most of the cases it's
sufficient to just uh take this um
application and um scan the scan the
trench and submit the data to us um and
in this web application where then the
data is being received from on our end
we have our construction supervisors
working with it um and they see directly
what is the current state of the
construction so where's it's it's a life
progress monitoring um we can we can
identify um which uh construction method
has been used um we directly can see all
the images being taken in the field um
we also see um what was the planed
Network and where deviations to that um
we can see the um yeah the meter
measurements um it's it's basically
giving us the the overview of the um
complete construction um happening in
the field um and also in in cases where
we need uh more details uh to and need
to do more for example quality assurance
um and what has really been constructed
we can dig into
the information directive or the um yeah
the data um provided by this application
in towards the web app and we can
directly go into the trench and and do
for example measurements have has the
construction really been as deep as we
we asked for um is the trench as wide um
as has been uh submitted in the invoice
um so it helps us basically doing
quality assurance um helps us doing
reconciliations of the invoicing process
um and is then also later on being used
for the for the documentation process
towards our physical Network inventory
so we can in case of of questions we can
always then dig into more details on um
how did the trench actually look like
when it was still
open and that was basically in a
nutshell the the quick run through of um
the entire program of the FD
Factory um and with that I would then
pass back over to you
R yes thank you B thank you very much
for uh for that run through it's really
interesting to see how this process uh
was further improved and and how the end
to end uh yeah uh combination of these
Technologies really helped you automate
um the process so I I would just
summarize some of the key takeaways here
I I think when we started this project
uh having an ambition to go into
millions three four five million we've
seen actually reached now uh of of true
put for ftth design at the beginning was
of course very challenging these are big
numbers and it's great to see that we
actually achieved that uh by working on
the uh on the whole automation of the
processes um and that has resulted in in
several reductions we've heard a lot of
different numbers I'm highlighting here
a 75% reduction in the design effort uh
but obviously you can see that there's a
lot of um optimizations in a lot of
processes uh which are really showing
the potential of these kind of
Technologies uh and last but not least I
think it's great how you showed also the
importance of um Gathering data at high
quality um and uh how that helps to also
um improve the overall quality of what
you're generating in your process um and
driving the efficiency of the processes
um so thanks for sharing that uh that's
really great and with that I think we
can uh take some questions uh I guess
from No Doubt from the audience uh
Vincent have you had a look at that yeah
absolutely R um I think we we already
have some questions so I'll I'll start
very soon but I just want to encourage
uh you know even more participant to to
ask their question use the question box
in the control panel as I said during
the introduction even if we cannot cover
them although we have a 25 minutes to
take quite a few questions so it's going
to be very engaged please do not
hesitate to ask your question um so I'll
start with um the very first one uh
question from adaya R how do you check
external lines
um okay how do you check external lines
do you get the question back I'm not
sure what I'm I'm assuming how do we
check um whether there's con is already
something in the ground when we do our
construction and um don't don't mess up
uh the infrastructure of of other
competitors or other um infrastructure
providers I assume but the question is
very short there's no extra context
sorry about
it um Hing maybe in the towards the
planning process you can probably
elaborate how we um you when do we get
infrastructure from let's say local um
water and gas companies and how do we
make sure that we um yeah this is met
during the approval process so we have
to in Germany we have to um approve each
trench we made so not only the location
of the cabinets but but also the um the
trenches we met each meter has to be
approved by the local authorities and of
course um most of the local authorities
know their City they know where for
example some gas line is is present or
something like that so here we get our
first information if there's already
something in the ground that we might be
that might be damaged during our uh
construction process so this is the
first step and the second step is during
the construction itself each
Construction Company um have to ask um
for example the the power provider um if
there's something in the ground so we
have some kind of two-step system here
to avoid damage to some other
infrastructure yeah maybe I can add from
a more broader perspective that it's
indeed often part of the cycle uh for
example what we've seen as well is with
um Network deployments which maybe go on
poles or on aerial uh or on on facades
of buildings which are part of the
design but then no permit or or the
polls are not able to take those um
cables in a later stage I think the the
power is that you always have to be able
to adapt to this kind of new input um
and and rapidly redesign taking in new
new information of where where you're
blocked or where you can't go and I
think that's what is really easy in this
kind of automated process because if you
change the input you adapt the options
automatically you can recalculate the
the whole network end to endend within
minutes okay I have a question from Luke
um related to how the AI work in a city
center environment where there are
typically many parked cars which could
uh cover
sidewalks um so what is your he's
talking about percentage of success is
in in in a variety of environment and
how do you work out the situation uh
described as non-successful uh
street so we do have um I mean that
that's one of the reasons that we that
we don't use a smaller car like a I
don't know a golf or anything like that
but that we actually do rely on having a
sprinter because the cameras are then so
far higher up and we can actually see
behind
cars um in many instances at least um
but in addition we also have um aerial
data available so in cases where our car
cannot be used for example also
pedestrian zones or these cases where
there is a lodge blockage or a truck
parked on the side we then use aerial
data in addition uh in the
classification process um and yes then
it's uh extrapolation of the data so
there is obviously some instances where
we don't have the data and where we then
just have to extrapolate on what we see
in the surrounding and and use that
information okay very
clear
um question on duct
infrastructure um is it taken into
account by commo or or how is uh Telecom
um handling uh the the duct
infrastructure within within the
planning so which infrastructure the the
I guess the underground uh
infrastructure I assume in the
question yeah maybe I can kick off uh
because if I understand the question
correctly it's indeed can we take
existing ducts into consideration and
the answer is yes we will add as a
separate layer in the design process uh
information about where existing ducts
are geographically uh and of course if
they're if they have a certain capacity
um and then that will be considered
within the whole yeah automated
calculation of of how the network looks
because that is obviously in some cases
an um yeah an extra uh cheaper way to
reach a certain point but I think um
well I think B told and anding you
already alluded to it that uh there is a
lot of complexity in how you can
actually use for example some customers
have certain ducts which they are um
okay to break open somewhere halfway to
to go out uh or they may not allow that
that for example would already be a
completely different way of treating
this kind of information in the design
optimization so I don't know if you want
to add a little bit more on how you
exactly treat those that
DT yes yes maybe I can I can give a
little insight so as you've already
maybe seen on on our slides um this
whole topic of existing uh
infrastructure was pretty challenging
for us because do teom has a lot of um
existing conduits and ducts already
placed uh all around Germany so um how
we handled this well as RF already said
there's a separate um layer for existing
infrastructure and we import all of our
existing infrastructure from our
inventory system so we have an interface
here and this is also
yeah transferred manually so the planner
or employee only defines the yeah the
area in which he wants to have the our
existing infrastructure imported and
then we just import it out of our in
inventory and then it's taken into
account by by comsoft by the fiber
designer in an automated way so there
are some some attributes which have to
be uh filled out so for example the
capacity of an existing pipe and then
you we know okay there for example one
existing pipe which has a capacity of
100 mm and then the conso designer um
tries to uh use this existing pipe um in
a cost efficient way yeah so it's it's
pretty um pretty nice solution which is
available here okay uh there's a mix of
of you know very technical very precise
question and some question are more
General so maybe I'll I'll uh I'll
insert this one in the conversation it
goes a bit beyond what is covered today
but the question reads um what is the
the competitive environment in Germany
do you have multiple operator building
networks are they over building in the
same location so maybe a more General
context to to what uh you've been
describing
here so yes we do have a competitive
environment and yes we um even though
it's uh hopefully not often the case but
there is um also happening of
overbuilding um there's basically two
main programs in Germany so one is where
we um we and all the competitors
basically make their plans for
themselves and say this area is is um
promising for us so therefore we're
going to do a self-funded roll out um
there's in addition subsidized rollouts
um that are subsidized by the government
and and you have to apply for these uh
roll out areas and only one of the
competitors would get um the um subsidy
and would get the um or then obviously
start to build out this area most of
these cases otherwise the area would not
be um would not be as interesting um and
therefore it's only one company actually
doing
it and you want to add
something no if it's
fun okay um how often do you have to to
to alter to to modify your design path
after doing a a field
check so not so often not not not so
often so of course there will be changes
in each Network design so not I didn't
experience even one network design which
was one what which was 100% built
outside so there will be always changes
to the network design and um to which
step we have to go back so if we there
only small changes then this can be can
be done in the detail planning so for
example if there's um a construction
site on the plan route then of course we
have to go to the other side of the
street or something like that we have to
find another way to connect our our
homes so there are always changes in the
in the in the network design itself but
we didn't have to go back and generate a
complete in new network design yet
although our our roll out areas are
pretty big but all these changes could
be done um either by the by the um
detailed planner or by the construction
company
itself so I really did not experience
any any any construction documents which
have to really go back to the high level
design step we do with
com and and I would like to add to this
that I think there indeed what you
presented in in terms of end to end
process is really helping that because
of course everything depends on the
quality of your input if you want to run
an automated calculation but you do it
on input data which is not which already
starts with having uh not all the the
information about the area then of
course you end up with uh choices made
Based on data which is not correct which
can also result in in wrong choices and
in that case field survey is important
to actually update that so for sure we
have customers who will have to correct
maybe uh 30 40% after the field survey
in in terms of rerunning and iterating
on the design and and we support that uh
in in an as as easy as possible way but
I think here it's really great to see
how the process also is is optimized to
get that data quality uh on the input
side as good as possible and that will
reduce of course the work you have
afterwards to Cor cor
things okay I have two question which I
would like to combine maybe in one there
is a first question related
to which probably is linked to the fact
that the the person asking is not very
familiar with the detail of the the
construction method and and regulation
in Germany so is it are you able to
reuse existing duct do you reuse
poles um or do you need to go for New
duct every time are they possibility or
impossibility to use overhead Roots so
that that's one question you will
address and I have another one which is
a bit larger but based on your
experience and your knowledge maybe on
of what happens in other um country in
Europe what sort what sort of takeaway
would you uh would you share uh with uh
operators from from other region from
your experience uh that is presented
today so maybe that's something RF can
complete on first question on on uh how
do you roll out and and what method of
deployment you you have to
use yeah so in in Germany obviously most
of the construction is underground um so
there's very little appetite for doing
aerial constructions M if so then only
in rural areas but all over um the
cities and I would say probably 90%
probably more is under Underground
Construction um and yes we definitely
want to reuse our existing
infrastructure and our existing ducts I
mean that's the main asset that telecom
already has in the ground um it would
have been so much easier to just ignore
that in infrastructure from an from a IT
program perspective um and there were we
even in the beginning thought about uh
wouldn't it be for a first uh First Step
be easier to just say okay the first
area we just do all always um open
construction but that's that's the main
uh cost saving that we can apply in dut
Telecom because we have such a vast uh
infrastructure already in the ground um
and therefore yes we definitely want to
reduse it we we also overtime um
implemented methods to also reuse
partially available infrastructure which
may be already partially used and is uh
it's has still some spare capacity um so
that's one of the main things that we
had to introduce into the overall
program um to make use of the existing
infrastructure um and um that is also
already available in our physical
Network
inventory and sorry for the second part
of the question the second question is
what sort of guidance takeaway can you
share with maybe you know other operator
having maybe slightly different uh uh
infrastructure rules from your
experience of of using this kind of
tools again maybe just from from the
perspective what we had also talking to
our nut go um across Europe where we
also wanted or talked about introducing
this this progress and process stream um
we we did have these interactions as
well and um in other countries there are
obviously different rules on how much do
you have to do underground um we had a
conversations where we said okay for us
it's really important to understand what
the surface type is because depending on
the surface type the reinstatement is is
quite uh from a cost perspective quite
different so Cobblestone is obviously
much more expensive than plowing through
grass um and um what we had from some of
the um other countries who had the
feedback well for us it doesn't really
matter what we use to reinstate the um
the surface back into and therefore we
don't need that detailed information um
so obviously depends on local uh local
requirements but for us um yeah one one
of the main cost driver for the whole
construction is um the uh the
underground construction and therefore
um uh the cost driver is reinstatement
and of of all of that and uh therefore
we needed uh that detailed information
that may be different in other areas
where that's uh where that's not the
case dra do you want to take that
further one uh yes well I C I certainly
uh can agree with you having looked at a
lot of yeah deployments in different
countries that there is a big difference
also in a big difference in the way in
uh the the choices are made and
optimization is is driven because unit
costs for example could already be even
within two countries building
underground networks uh the the balance
of unit costs could already be quite
different um because of for example
access to cheaper labor or for example
the depth at which you need to deploy uh
if you can do micr trenching that is 30
CMS deep you get a completely different
cost for an underground Network and that
will actually drive different decisions
in in the optimal topology so all of
these local differences are important to
consider when you look at at the local
situation um but I would also highlight
in uh as a takeaway for for other um T
Cs and looking at what has been done
here I think what is uh really nice is
to start a bit with the end in mind
that's what I always like to do is
looking at this okay where do we what do
we want to achieve and what will the
endtoend process look like and think
about an integrated solution that can
cover that end to-end process and then
if you would look at the history we've
had through the 5 years of course the
solution did not
fall out of the sky in one year so I
think what what then is an interesting
takeaway that you can actually start off
with something and then gradually add
more components into the process that
further improve the speed and the
accuracy of of the process um and
thinking that through and really
thinking out how that process should
work and doing that in a fully digitized
way because hey well we're 2023 almost
202 before so uh there's a lot of
benefits of thinking that through really
well and then implementing it uh face by
face so to
say okay thank you um another question
for for you belal um question about how
how has
your the question reads how is your
demand changing in 23 versus 22 and how
do you foresee 24 I guess by demand they
are thinking about
activity and and and investment plan in
fiber
um um yeah I mean could could see from
our figures on the on the first slid
we're constantly ramping up I mean we've
been uh I think it was 2.2 million to uh
this year and last year it's going to be
more likely 3 million next year so
theand is obviously constantly ramping
up um it's it's I mean the the goal for
for whole of Germany um for all of the
competitors in Germany is that that all
of Germany should be connected to fber
by 2030 um so that's still a long way to
go um and therefore I think the the
demand for us in terms of construction
is constructing the network is
definitely High um and um yeah so the
the the plan is to to have more and more
people also being then not only
constructive but physically connected uh
to the Cyber but I'm not sure that
completely addresses question but yeah
but I think that was the spirit of the
question um I have another one which
becomes uh much more Technical and
practical from Molly she's asking what
what percentage of the process remains
manual uh if you look at the different
stages of preparation and planning what
part is still um done really
manually I mean for that maybe that's
that's a big lesson learned for us um
when we started off the program we we
had the intention every should be
automated we want to run the entire
process stream automated we want to do
also documentation automated and only
the very few deviations we would uh then
try to to make them manual and we
learned over time that this was this was
also not feasible also with our existing
processes and um with the way how how um
how the the planners and and designers
and everyone has been using the systems
in the past and therefore we try we had
to put more we had to open up the whole
stream for more flexibility because if
if we were to go for the fully automated
process there would be only one process
and only one way of doing it but we we
didn't have any flexibility anymore um
and therefore we had to open it up again
and to allow for for more flexibility
but that also then means more manual
Intervention which is also asked for by
our planners because
the the program wouldn't every single
time do the right decision you you end
up with cabinets that from all the
aspects that we just learned on the map
and everything they look perfect but
then if you go to the field you realize
they're standing in in front of a
shopping window and you can't see the
window anymore so you need flexibility
you need um changes to be possible and
therefore we had also our detailed
design is now not completely automated
it's it's a set of tools that helps the
designer to be much more efficient and
much more quicker but it's still a
manual process um and we changed to that
manual process we had it more automated
and it it didn't uh we didn't have any
user acceptance with that process and we
are deliberately now into a
semi-automated process um and and trying
to tweak that further and help giving
more efficiencies to the planners but
still allow them to do the the planing
job
manually thank you I'm just conscious of
time uh I would like to give you the
opportunity Bel to to look um ahead and
maybe share with the audience what are
your plans in term of maybe further
integration of iqg tools or further
Improvement in your processes moving
forward how do you see the the Evolution
for for the next two three years uh in
term of of your methodology to to to
gain more efficiency and be faster and
and lower your
costs so in terms of integration with
with tools so for example com comor FIV
has been integrated uh already since
2020 and it's fairly stable and works
perfectly for us now and um that's
that's the valuable piece for us to to
start the whole process so would say our
um our structure planning is very stable
and probably needs tweaking over the
next couple of years wherever we change
network design rules um but but the main
integration component is is more or less
achieved in in that component uh same
for the detail design I think that runs
very stable and smooth and we will have
further uh efficiencies there but the
integration is is more or less completed
um what is our main component that we
are building right now is the whole area
around the digital construction support
um and we um a few of the components
that I mentioned before are not up on
early stages of um of um MVPs and and
piloting and um so the the whole
integration of that component um then
also integration with our pni system to
do the automated documentation
integration with some um some invoicing
components um that will be taking most
of our uh energy in time for the next
year I
believe well thank you so much um R
maybe I give you one minute to conclude
so we we close the this session on time
yeah yeah um well first of all I would
like to thank our speakers again and I
think it's been
um Illustrated also by the amount of
questions that there's a number of
unanswered questions which I I think
we'll cover later on but I think it's
it's been great to see the interaction
and the questions for this topic so
there's clearly a big um interest I I
think it's really an illustration it's
been and it's been a journey as as the
title said
uh of of many years where we um yeah
where we got to that stage now of of
high productivity and a great example uh
process so we're happy to share a bit
more details how that went on individual
basis for anybody that has questions
feel free to reach out um and with that
yeah I'd like to thank also of course
the audience and uh look forward to more
of these kind of webinars into next year
no doubt I hope you're working on that
vent well absolutely we we have I mean
replay of our webinar available via our
website I would definitely also
encourage our audience to re to check
our website a lot of content uh covering
this type of uh tech technical
discussion but also many other aspect of
at in Europe can be downloaded for free
from our website so don't hesitate to uh
to check uh and uh watch out for the
next invitation we will have a webinar
in January on on another topic so with
that uh thank you uh all thanks many
thanks to to our speakers wish you a
good end of the year uh Merry Christmas
uh and I hope to see you all uh well
maybe next year in Berlin uh when we
have our uh our annual conference uh at
the end of March so I'm I'm sure Dutch
Telecom will be well represented among
uh speakers and and audience there thank
you so much uh have a good rest of your
day thank you very much thank you thank
you